now dr jesus jarrow will remain in his
position as superintendent after coming
to an agreement with the majority of the
ccsd school board thank you for joining
us tonight at 11 i'm sasha loftis dr
jarroz says it's now time to move
forward kate houston is live in studio
after speaking with board president
linda cavazos and kate there are some
key issues she wants to collaborate on
with jara and her fellow trustees yes
sasha cavazo says some top issues are
developing clear communication between
trustees and superintendent jarrah as
well as raising district-wide morale in
a statement on friday dr jarrah said
focus should also be on issues such as
student safety and mental health
i'm very hopeful to getting to a better
place because
i feel that the
community deserves that cavazo says the
agreement with dr jara includes
assurances for everyone involved that
we're going to be working toward common
goals for student achievement and
looking at what is going to be best for
our district our students our employees
our community cavazo says morale needs
to be addressed noting educators are
leaving and students are confused we
cannot forget about the boots on the
ground we cannot forget about our bus
drivers our food service workers our
teachers the these are the people who
kept everything going for our children
during the pandemic there are some
timely issues that jarrah could address
in the coming weeks including the
employee covid 19 vaccine mandate once
ccsd and employee unions come to an
agreement it would go back before the
board cavasso says she has not received
an update on that i myself have made
some inquiries on that as far as the
timeline because we have a lot of people
that are concerned about that and with
good reason you know they want to know
what is this going to look like moving
forward cavazo says they're looking at
other avenues such as mediation to
settle some issues that have not been
finalized
he is our only employee
and if we don't have that clear
communication if these assurances do not
flow both ways
then we cannot be successful
when it comes to the vaccine mandate the
school administrators union says they
recently received an email from a ccsd
negotiator they were asking to meet and
to see where they stand on the vaccine
mandate issue a meeting has not been set
yet sasha